Today's video is sponsored by NordVPN. Hey guys I'm Nate welcome back to the workshop today. We're gonna take something
That's not normally very secure and see if we can build something strong out of it
We're gonna make a puzzle box using Lego pieces
This is not supposed to be an exact set of
Step-by-step instructions because the different building blocks that everyone may have available will change from place to place
But the ideas that we're gonna be using should be able to be used and expanded on with what you've got available
We've got a bunch of our Lego bricks. Let's get started assembling the first thing
I want to do is make the inner box that will eventually hold our prize
Start by giving ourselves a base and you may notice
I'm not wearing gloves today, and it's because my gloves are black and most of these pieces are black and I'd
I just don't want everything to blend together on camera. We want to give ourselves the most inside space on this box
We're gonna need some walls
I like these large pieces with a flat open areas partly because if we install them with
Open side in it gives us a little bit more
Interior space than we would get if we just built up the walls with normal bricks. I've got a few of these
different styles that
Should give us a little bit more interior space
Build up some walls around this
Alright, there's a box that will hold some stuff. We're gonna want our box to be removable from whatever security
We build around it
So let's use some of these smoother pieces to attach onto the top and then hopefully that will let us
Slide the box in and out of its case more easily now
We need to build a larger box that goes around this one and can lock in place
So it's not just a box in a box, but it's a box locked in a box
So let's use some more of these smooth pieces to give ourselves a little bit of a sliding surface
Those are the same length as our box so that way we should be able to have the box slide nicely on those rails
Nice and slidey perfect lets throw a slider on the front
That's not really gonna help with the movement much
But it is gonna make it more of a continuous flat plane our box doesn't look like it's just sort of
Floating over the rails. It's not quite so obvious where the access point is gonna be so this is a good sliding base
But it's not gonna secure it much, so let's start adding a little bit onto the sides
We've now extended our base with a larger square underneath it
I think we'll be able to use that to build more walls and a ceiling around our strongbox
While that plastic wall is getting built, let's talk about our sponsor for today's video NordVPN
Which helps build a digital wall around your data online
use of unsecured or public Wi-Fi at places like coffee shops
airports or hotels is among the easiest ways for hackers to access your sensitive info in the time it takes for you to check a
Few emails or your social media someone can easily scrape logging or other sensitive info passed beyond the really bad guys
recent changes to net neutrality
Laws mean your ISP can start throttling bandwidth as well as collecting and selling more info about your browsing all stuff
That's easy to prevent with a VPN Virtual Private Networks
Essentially build a wall around your info a little stronger than a lego lockbox protecting it from such prying eyes
Nord double encrypts all your info regardless of whether you're on your phone laptop
or at home on a desktop
And they do not keep any logs of your activity like some other VPNs and as an added bonus it even comes with a free
Ad blocker Nord received an Editors Choice Award and was the only
VPN to receive a perfect score from PC Mag NordVPN is offering king of random fans
77% off of a three-year plan go to NordVPN.com/random or click the link in the description to sign up and start
protecting yourself
I Think by using some of these bricks with the holes in it we may be able to add something of a locking mechanism
onto our box let's take out one of the bricks in our inner box and
add in a brick that has a hole in it and maybe then we can get them to line up and work as a
lock
Those holes lining up if we put in this three brick wide peg
That should lock it in place now
It's lined up flush with the front of our secure box
But it can't move anywhere until that peg is pulled out
This isn't very flush right now the sides aren't coming up as high as our inner box
Let's just add a little bit more on to that we can add a ceiling on to it
Now our inner box is entirely contained, and it doesn't move until we pull out our lock once we pull out the lock
That can slide out so that's level one of our security, but we can go more secure instead of just pushing it out
I think we can build a mechanism that will push it out for us in fact since it's a lock box
I really kind of like the idea of having a key something you put into a slot and turn
To really get the box out got here one of our little plus cross-section little
Sticks. I don't really know the name for all the different terms, but it should work pretty well to make our skeleton key
Let's add a tooth on to it
Lets add some of these little pegs just to hold that tooth right where we want it in place
I've Got one of these little wheel pieces that has the same
Plus cross-section designed to fit over these so let's add that on and that to me looks like a key
It's as I said not the fanciest key in the world
but it will turn and it'll be a key let's try and build something that lets us twist our key and
Have that be the mechanism that pushes the box out
He goes in here we want to stop it from going any farther
And now it has a nice little spot that it will lock into place
Build a back wall on so our key doesn't fly out in the wrong spot
We've got these side bricks that are full of the holes
And I kinda want to just keep using that aesthetic a little bit, I'm gonna put of those pieces on the back here
Just need to
There you go
So now we've added a keyhole on to the back of our box, and we still have the whole thing as one
Entire integral unit well our key is working and our lock is working
But our key is still just sort of you know
Where do you keep the key to make sure that's secure I don't want to just carry it on my pocket
This is a lego key. I might break it. I might lose it I
Think I would like to have it with the box, but I want the key to be secure as well
To just have it sitting on top. It's a little easy to find so I think we can build a whole
Disguising mechanism for our key as well
So our key has space to fit on top
We would need to build walls around it and then like I said I want the key to be hidden
I don't want the key to just be sitting there. I think what I want to do is have a lid that
conceals itself flush with the rest of the pieces and then a secret button that we can push that will lift the lid or
Reveal the lid so we can access our key inside
Push on this piece it will lift the top up out of the way that way we can have the top
Attached and flush to what's around it with our push of a secret button
It can lift up and show us the access point
At the moment our button is shorter than our key so we're gonna need to lift that up
Just make the walls taller than that the walls of course need to be at least
high enough to hide our key inside
You do want the button to slide nicely, let's add in a smooth panel
That can let our button just sort of slide where we want it to go
When we push our button in it does tend to pop out entirely we don't want to lose our button
We just want to be able to push in and then come back out
Let's see if we can build sort of a retaining wall something will hold it in on the sides
Don't really want the outside of our box to have much color
But this is gonna be on the inside so I think we can afford just a little bit
brighter colors
Some brighter colored pieces
Nice
I'm liking how that's looking
Now our our lid like I said, it doesn't really go on very well
We need to add some attachment points where it's something that will just hold it in place where we want it to go
We don't want to get in the way of our key
So let's try and just go through the corners where it's not gonna be interfering with our key at all
And our lid still isn't quite as wide as the whole wall going around our box
So let's take one side of our wall in by one brick layer, and then add some corner supports
Let's get a little bit more support in this corner
Now it's sturdy it doesn't fall off and let's try pushing our button here
Hey that pops right off
Now our plate is not very well disguised at this point and there's still a little Ridge where you can grab it
So I want to cover the whole plate and the border using some smooth pieces
And I hope that we'll just sort of disguise it and make it so you can't get your fingers on to it or just take
Another brick push it down onto the plate and peel it up like that
Our secret pop top design is working pretty nicely
At this point our puzzle box is mostly done, but there's one more thing
I want to do just to make it a little more secure
This one peg is very obvious people are gonna know that you need to do something with this pegs
So let's take all of these other holes going around our whole box and fill those with pegs as well
This particular peg is three bricks wide and we know that it extends through one layer
Into our interior box to hold it securely in place quite a fill on the rest of them
We just use these two brick wide pegs
They'll look the same from the outside, but disguise the functionality of the important one
We now have a secured compartment with three stages to get inside
We first have to hit the secret button to pop off the lid we can then remove the key from
inside the top compartment
But as we know our hidden key isn't going to do anything
Until we know which of these pegs going around is our secret lock
When you pull that out of the way it disengages and at that point we can turn our key to reveal our hidden compartment
Everything easily resets gets put back in place and is hidden once again
For unlimited reuse and remember you don't have to follow this exact design
This is showing you the kind of things you can do to make a cool little
multistage puzzle out of some Legos
Thanks again to NordVPN the sponsor for today's video go to NordVpn.com/random
or click the link in the description below to get seventy seven percent off of a three year plan
Guys thanks for watching if you aren't a subscriber yet just hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video
Or want to check it out again. Just click up here at the top click down there
If you want to see what the internet thinks you should be watching next that's it for now have fun
Be safe, and see you tomorrow